we thought they'd be good here but we
weren't really thinking they were gonna
be the twt champion yeah yeah that's
definitely true that's definitely true
and on top of that the game has changed
we're going to the long set ladies and
gentlemen this is first to three winners
finals dictate you need three games to
win huh still hope these guys will be
alive but somebody's going down to that
loser side to be waiting in finals for
the winner of an acute versus all time
just go zero hundred fifty miles per
hour
like yes oh damn all right with the
characters jeez Howard and Sergey
dragging a butt oh yeah got a few
thoughts nobody percent me we're gonna
have peace Howard going up against deep
box from me oh my gosh all right guys
here we go it's getting crazy right now
if you guys like me to make it to Grand
Finals and make some noise out there
oh that's no way that's all acquiesce
whatever that's all the Koreans we got
out there I'm gonna ask you again if you
guys like rocks dragons need to make it
to grandfather's make some noise but
what about Chickering if you think
chicken is gonna take out knee and make
it to Grand Finals make some noise out
there
I mean I think you talked him into it
though yeah I guess you're cheating you
gotta leave winners final first two
three get off nice break on that throw
that one plus two you going with the
Steve Fox big here and already starting
that pressure with that down to
forgotten ramps lots of floors the
brakes it's gonna be chipping away at
each other and that's chicken style
right like nothing really heavy like to
just poke you down these down to these
down fours down forward one all day and
the finally get to don't wanna go for
the meter on it place it really though
right a lot of sound to from Steve down
for the ones it's good walk then
one-twos out of him max one-twos yep
tossed him three trying to open up me
but he still has the unlikely that was
gonna be a lot harder to get that off
and trying to get some player like me I
mean he is rocking the geese though
chicken just getting that third bar bill
to put me now what's it been a rage 15
seconds on the clock still upstairs just
pace it take it this time back three
does have that meter though there it is
spent it already inside step three
yeah man look at these so solid not
gonna flinch with it underneath the high
get it out of here I'm familiar I know
it's new I don't even see many people
took that planet no I mean it's
basically just used for cobblers right
so you really have an opportunity in a
match actually Duquette okay stairs we
go first
no problem is back at one girl I bought
it just for you he tried to sidestep
three four okay and he just stood up and
back one though this plant get off I'm a
boxer we don't do that here look at the
movement for me albatross to get in
Chickering on the ropes I said get away
from he breaks another throat yeah
albatross pin to nothing
10 seconds left on the clock defense of
me holding up your chick would having a
hard time breaking him down here oh my
god that was so sick he goes straight
into it to that nut then none
go straight to the range art brush ooh
God
I don't even hear it see dinner right
there
one round the piece but got down for two
a four-for-one a follow-up you wouldn't
need to get in there try the advance was
gonna work out though had the four full
weight back to the slow pacing chick
would steal working on a perfect issue
yeah you know he's trying to psyche of
all these I can't believe over the low
counter there maybe trying to get a read
on these down to timing great break on
the wall plus 2 again both of these guys
awake no sleeping at the wheel here I'm
trying to get to this grand finals oh
yes you can win that's gonna be a lot of
money on life without way oh boy I don't
want to tell you what it is man
that's a pretty money differential right
now rage for D though Chikara dollar for
all right the reppuken just back and
forth moving sidestepping and then lets
it rip at the last time and catches
already he hit back reaches not on hitch
does not burn the metaphor get the save
that meter and we should go to that a
few times to start around situations
just back to to immediately but here we
go finally Perth beat it does not find
hits at this time that could come back
to haunt them see me just waiting I find
the water come along go downstairs what
do you want downstairs on clam bake
big damage oh my god no anything final
round
one I check her employees in danger of
going down this first game first two
three will be going to Grandpa the
winner that is now punch that was sexy
that excited about their Putin got the
beatdown for the whip punished wow this
hospital oh my god
he doesn't go for the compa like you
said before he's just simple takes the
damage get out of it Shikha really close
to that wall right and get dangerously
though he isn't raged and he's got a
huge lead but chick with does that one
part gosh going to chicken in there back
and forth you know look like me kind of
a terrine up things but chicken save
that one bar these are found in opening
use the rage at the end of it made a pan
that's why geese is still so dangerous
of a character right I mean look they
keep saying like every season he gets
both nerfed you know Sam doesn't mean
those good players aren't gonna still be
able to utilize him and do amazing
things Chickering one of those players
committing to the character of course he
has other characters but I feel like
he's he's playing at the smart way you
make these people fight you a lot harder
than you fight them yeah you remember
when season so you came out chicken was
kind of exploring moving away from geese
Howard he went kind of back to Jin for a
little bit he's like you know this geese
guys still pretty good yeah I think I'm
just figuring out you know what I think
I'm gonna stay around man yeah this can
give you top three to the TW finals
great style walk
hey dr. Perry yeah exactly he's done a
really great job of that right mixing up
and timing on okey so that's a counter
timing from chicken is throwing off
rocket launcher great massage weird
Thailand baby oh wow
pretty far away 25 seconds left on the
clock chicken enrage again but don't
beat at this time around that's gonna go
to him that first round game number two
that's how we need if you look back that
was a bowler - back - size up left and
he got prepared out that width of a
punny perfectly can't really just runs
on geese wet specimens got that Bart
load it up oh they are shocking right
now yeah it's definitely dancing a
little bit back one back one back down
to it back one you recognize that
chicken had the bar do whether you want
to bait it out there sounded opening dr.
BAE down the boom back one oh now see
once again down for chicken trying to
find it open it now yeah that's what I'm
talking about no feeder but it's only 15
seconds left on the clock that's gonna
oh no wall that could be huge me adopted
we get back are we gonna see her way to
dive down back to me maybe there it is
sonic drive block seven seconds needs
behind here can t find over even three
seconds to go no no chicka wrench steals
an exit the next round in his game this
is so solid right chicken just dig
foucault I'm not panicking very
important that kind of a situation
interesting kind of threw away that
meter there
I mean I feel like you just wanted me to
run it and we want some let's try to be
more offensive so you can find and open
it Belize is not giving it mm-hmm ain't
very preemptable these won't support the
defensive player be sure and you'll see
so many times chick we just dug these
single down like those those duck he's
not even doing down forward window this
is single down not even trying to fish
for Lopez just throwing off these timing
okay fake them out another way fake them
out with the movement you don't only
have to put you know an actual but now
exactly chicory right now game number
two one match point you're right this
music too good it's too good dude
chickens got a bar though this is
winners final he's up won 2-0 he can't
land a hit here and get to a wall he's
basically gonna win the round
oh yeah he definitely has that warm
artists stop block the boat it doesn't
find itself and East Side walking away
he's lost a lot of healthier though and
time still on his side
thirty seconds right at about the in
trouble though getting real close to
Ray's trying to start that off and
there's the ball we were talking about
he eat get off
wait to throw spins it earlier back
three two after the blocking steal nice
roll and knees and twelve your time
winding down he doesn't really have a
good option to make it come back here
can he find a where his chicken gonna
run away with Game two right now his
nollie is just for me eight seconds on
the clock just walk off the locker can
you find them out down back me to see be
some crabmeat ties it up here oh that
time
so sick Eve knew if he got any other hit
he would have lost look it she's going
crazy yo Japan the energy is electric
that's what I'm talking about
kicker oh my he's up to to zero right
now over knee and knee not gonna switch
characters he's going right back into it
with Deepak Mishima dojo for the rematch
keep something like this that uh that
Anika me rematch it's true I say it's
very possible to get the throat and the
running run Oh
counter hit on top of me big damage
there's so many people calls you a long
set player I'll do much better
tournament palace what up
I mean he played like a thousand matches
one day right won't sit well look at
chicken right now it's a jocular lost f2
bro is that you know we went there first
right I think I knew about this I knew
it was good you had the recent
hyperbolic time chips but I was there
before I wasn't there chillin man down
for one catching eat write a new
possibly duck Hulk spins the ball gotta
get the walkouts for it one plus two
spins to either miss the second oh oh
man he's getting beat up right now
chicken a total control set point right
now on the side of chicken hey man like
I said chicken went there first he knows
that he was benefits geese Oh back one
put him asleep standing up he gonna get
the wall
oh man that hurts I thought you know
what's a good massage mmm beautiful get
a massage you get that I'm not really
sure okay okay sure you can get that
around back leave out of this just yet
yeah Mandy is hitting a lot of bunt
there between rounds he feels the
pressure for sure trying to find some
answers here it's two more rounds in a
row
I like the faces on both sides here he
knows he has to be a lot more curb up
chanting taystee
okay okay wall carries good as well
don't like 65% off Drake final round
still set point for chicken here board
the sweep over knee if you can get done
two bars on the side of chicken oh wow I
thought he was gonna pounce will be
face-first
repeater bone I bet you I'll do it again
he might and just blows the bar right
away yeah chicken working on a perfect
sled the bar to go me has great oh okay
wait a minute the wall what the hell was
that a man nerds get to us all too
sometimes maybe just wants a grand
finals is the ticket that chicken just
cashed he's gonna be waiting for whoever
makes it out of that loser side that is
unbelievable chicken advancing to the
winner's side of Grand Finals SEC
guarantees of a top to finish minimum of
$50,000 guaranteed for Chikara $50,000
guaranteed minimum for chicken here in
this tournament here impressive stuff
and you know no one really expected
you're gonna go this far man he's great
player but the tournament is so stacked
that he didn't expect it
you've said it multiple times no one
expects it no one expected the people
who win those two win twt to actually
win them and here we have another
opportunity we still got all side you
still got Annika down there there's the
brand is still alive waiting on that
finals and like I said ripp is not too
far away and it can't just have to get
this victory overall sign or it might go
the other way all songs been playing
amazing look at the peg play I mean if
you all you need to do is look at the
matches that we saw earlier today and
that's gonna give you a small hint but
it could still go either way
the thing is I feel like bull son hasn't
really lost to the heck you know yes
it's